packed and ready for departure tens of
thousands of people from the city of
wuhan
are on the move after 76 days hold up in
their homes
i plan to go home during the chinese new
year but because of the epidemic i
didn't get to do so
my family asks me every day when can i
come home
the lockdown has been gradually lifted
over the last 10 days
with inbound travel allowed but no
departures
on wednesday all major highways were
reopened
so too was the city's airport at least
55 000 people bought train tickets
to travel to other parts of china
i haven't been out since january 21st
this is the first time i've left the
house
now i'm going back home to meet my
parents
checkpoints remain but for health scans
those passengers carrying a green code
on a government health app
are considered low risk and can travel
to me
we will have a follow-up disinfection of
passengers
at the entrance and exits on the railway
station
the temperature screening and the health
code checking
are very strict 11 million people live
in the city known as a key industrial
hub of china
in december hospitals in wuhan reported
the first cases of the coronavirus
with an increasing number of patients
complaining of flu-like symptoms
in january the city was put in lockdown
after it became clear
that the flu-like virus was highly
contagious and potentially deadly
residents were trapped so too were
workers on the eve of the chinese new
year holiday break
including claire who who works and lives
in beijing
but all my other friends or colleagues
who
were actually from muhan they cancelled
their
plane tickets last minute but i didn't
excite
i was i chose to come back earlier
before that so i felt like
now i've been locked out by everyone
wuhan accounts for more than three
quarters of coronavira's deaths in china
authorities are warning of a second wave
of potential infections
as lockdowns are lifted across the
country and people return to work
we appeal to the residents of our city
not to leave wuhan for non-essential
travel
and continue to leave home as little as
possible
the recovery of wuhan has been watched
worldwide
while the city attempts to return to
normal the trauma
could last for decades sarah clark
al jazeera